welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for black panther wakanda
forever which leaves us with tears and
with questions let's break down this
trailer frame by frame for the visual
details you might have missed
translations of every bit of wakanda
text that we see on screen and just
appreciation for the amazing production
design and the other deeper layers of
meaning that you might have overlooked
let's get started
the trailer opens with no woman no cry
by bob marley and the whalers but here
covered by nigerian singer temps by
marley's lyrics are often misinterpreted
as if you have no woman there's nothing
to make you cry but that's not the truth
it's not a song for men it's really a
song for women it means woman don't cry
whaler's bassist aston barrett in 2012
explained that the song is really about
the strength of women and encouragement
to be like a lion with or without a man
and barrett encouraging women to rise up
as lions applies to the women of this
movie nakia shuri ramonda okoye aneka
and river williams that despite their
tears they can still be strong feline
warriors in their own right nakia stands
on a beach with a mayan pyramid behind
her these types of pyramids and ruins
can be found throughout mexico along the
yucatan peninsula and the atlanteans in
this film are going to be connected to
ancient mayan culture neymar actor
tanaka huerta told vice that he had to
learn a language for this movie that was
based on ancient mayan we'll talk more
about how that affects the plot of this
movie but let's move
[Music]
on and good friends we've lost
so here romanda sits upon the wakandan
throne flanked by the dora milan and the
floor of this room that she shares with
the other tribe elders is the exposed
red clay floor of mount bashenga this
throne itself bears the wakanda letters
that translate to wisdom and loyalty and
notice how ramonda appears to have a
chunk of vibranium ore on her armrest
maybe the conflict in this movie has to
do with vibranium as a natural resource
that is being plundered both from the
wakandans and from the atlanteans to the
left in blue and purple is dorothy
steele as the elder of the merchant
tribe returning from the 2018 film
dorothy steele passed away at age 95 in
october 2021 after completing her work
for this film in the streets of wakanda
citizens dance in white clothes white is
what wakandans wear when they are in
mourning raimonda and shuri were both
wearing white to mourn tachaka's death
at the beginning of the 2018 film
comfort for your loss thank you nakia
now wakanda celebrates the life of
t'challa shuri grieves in a procession
with her mother ramonda over the marvel
studios logo that's also in white led by
the dorm alaje who in this very rare
occasion trade out their red uniforms
for these white robes so yes this film
will address chadwick boseman's death by
showing the death of t'challa how the
character has died remains unclear some
have wondered if this film might be set
during the blip maybe they could be
morning t'challa's dusting but that is
not possible because shuri was among the
dusted according to avengers end game
and shuri is in this movie also
according to everyone on cast and crew
this along with every other phase war
title aside from a couple flashbacks is
set definitively after the blip i just
hope that they don't make the actual
circumstances of its death a kind of
plot point to the movie like this movie
does not have to be a conspiratorial
mystery to solve how t'challa died but
rather story about what people do after
in his absence now the gate that they
are headed toward has a statue of
bashenga bashenga was the first black
panther and wakandan king who united the
tribes of wakanda and the one who first
consumed the heart-shaped herb to come
into communion with bost here you can
actually see bost sitting at bashanga's
feet but then notice the figure to the
right that is a female figure could it
be bashanga's wife her sister his
daughter his mother there is another
feline sitting at her feet which i
believe to be segment bost is derived
from bastet the egyptian feline goddess
the more peaceful of the perrine that
also includes the more aggressive feline
deity of sekhmet t'challa actually
mentioned both of these in civil war in
my culture dead it's not the end it's
marve stepping off point you reach out
with both hands and bust and segment
they lead you into the green belt where
you can run forever and by green belts i
think we all assume that that was the
ancestral plane but this green garden
may actually be the green belt on this
side of the plane the one that leads to
the ancestral plane this appears to be
the royal cemetery aka the necropolis of
wakanda so as the past couple titles of
the mcu have started to explore how
certain superheroes are avatars of
deities and how those deities are
actually represented in the marvel
universe and omnipotent city and thor
love and thunder including someone who
we thought was boss and a white furred
feline figure that i think might be
segment this film may now expand this
kind of mythology to include both the
black panther embossed and an ancestral
female companion empowered by segment
moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
there's another angle of the throne room
showing the dormilage in formation and
now the columns have writing on them we
can see in power then t'challa then our
hero and honor forever and we know from
some set photos that the full
transcription of this phrase is rest in
power king t'challa our hero twas an
honor wakanda forever and notice how
each platform represents a different
part of wakanda we actually saw these
platforms and the art behind them in the
2018 film on the left the column at the
guard's feet reads golden city that is
the name of the central metropolis of
wakanda the next one king's guard that
represents the dora milaje next one
river tribe that is the green cloak
tribe from warrior falls the tribe nakia
comes from and the fourth one mining
tribe that is the red cloaked tribe that
we saw at warrior falls and behind each
of these are tabloid symbols and red
clay much like the floor of this throne
room the one on the far left is a large
tree with expansive branches and equally
expensive roots likely the panther tree
that we see in the ancestral plain but
you may also be reminded of the
asgardian geytra cell world's tree it's
just always interesting when the mcu's
desperate mythologies parallel each
other in little ways like this then
ramonda now in black stands on the
shoreline that we think nakia is on and
notice some gray hairs are visible under
her headpiece she looks magnificent but
even she cannot hide the toll that her
life and losses have taken on her moving
on
here we see the birth of neymar neymar
is marvel's first mutant publication
date wise and now the vmc has finally
said the word mutation in the context of
kamala khan it's likely that they're
going to call neymar a mutant in this
movie as well namor is the mutant son
born to the atlantean princess of finn
and a human captain of the lemurian star
which kind of got referenced in winter
soldier target is a mobile satellite
launch platform the lemarian star yeah
lumerian star limerian star potato
topato now while dc's aquaman first
appeared in 1941 namor actually precedes
him joining captain america in the
android form of the human torch in 1939.
these three were the first real marvel
superheroes over the years namor has
been known as really an anti-hero who
seeks vengeance against surface dwellers
and in more recent comics has had a
history of bad blood with wakanda in
t'challa now atlantis has actually been
hinted at a few times in the mcu and
iron man 2 the world map that gave us
our first sighting of wakanda in the mcu
also included a site in the south
atlantic ocean and then end game had
that one line about the underwater
earthquakes you had a reading on those
tremors it was a mild subduction under
the african plate how are we handling it
it's an earthquake under the ocean
we handle it by not handling it and now
we actually get to visit atlantis and
meet these people it's interesting how
this mother gives birth in shallow water
you can see the surface right above her
head all the atlanteans that we see are
blue skinned as neymar's mother was in
the comics but here his mother may be
human thus the shallow water just a
human who might have fallen in love with
an atlantean father and that's why namor
isn't blue maybe his skin is a
reflection of his mutation let's move on
in this shot adult namor turns from a
large orb of light under water what is
this i'm wondering if this could be an
underwater explosion that neymar is just
turning away from in slow motion maybe
one of those mild subductions that okoye
brushed off but was actually the surface
dwellers mining away at namor's home
nymore wears a ceremonial mayan
headpiece with a jaguar head making
namor parallel to the black panther but
with the ferocious feline of central
america a helicopter approaches a human
research vessel but this isn't a purely
scientific mission because a guard is
holding a freaking machine gun and this
dive is occurring at night if you want
to see stuff under the ocean why
wouldn't you just go during the day yeah
this is not a harmless academic trip my
friends this actually might be the human
intervention that aggravates atlantis
and puts wakanda in an awkward situation
as wakanda unlike atlantis opened up to
the world community and thus from the
atlanteans point of view might have made
themselves culpable every time the
humans do something stupid moving on
okay now a different shot that i don't
think is part of that research vessel
here we see some armed uniformed
soldiers invading a wakandan lab forcing
a scientist to open a door and then
holding other scientists at gunpoint
beside these bubbling water columns this
could be an off-campus lab where i don't
know maybe some navy seals were sent to
take everything the wakandans know about
atlantis or maybe they're just there to
steal their vibranium actually later in
the trailer we do see the dormilage
coming to the scientists aid the fact
that a conflict though is happening
means that international relations are
probably going to [ __ ] then this insane
shot where shuri stands on the red clay
floor with the throne as fire climbs the
columns but a room around this floods
later shots in the trailer showed this
room of flooding and that is shocking
because again this room is atop mount
bashanga so for water to reach that high
it must have been an insanely tall tidal
wave and indeed as we see throughout the
trailer all of wakanda is going to flood
this movie looks like it's going to
closely adapt the 2012 avengers vs x-men
comic storyline in which and it's kind
of crazy just go with me on this the
phoenix forest takes five hosts one of
them namor and tracks down the avengers
to wakanda and then uses namor's
amplified powers to flood the entire
nation of wakanda killing countless
innocents so i assume in this movie the
atlanteans will flood wakanda as a kind
of final escalation maybe a measure of
last resort that begins with wakanda
siding with humanity over them but is it
going to be neymar who floods wakanda or
one of the other atlanteans that he
doesn't necessarily agree with the
extremity of let's play a quick round of
would you rather would you rather be up
at 6am for a flight to hawaii tomorrow
or meet up with your best friend who you
haven't seen forever who's only in town
for one night for a drink tonight
right question you can have a cocktail
or two with your college bud and make
your flight with time to have breakfast
beforehand even all you've got to do is
start your night by drinking the
zebiotix so zebiotics is a probiotic
drink that breaks down acetyl dehyde a
toxic byproduct of alcohol it's that
byproduct not dehydration that'll make
for the rough flight to hawaii after a
fun night of catching up with your old
friends so z-biotics is real science
that works you drink a zibiotix drink
responsibly pace yourself and you're
good to go
and that's it i just broke the curse of
would you rather i did it now it's your
turn get 15 off your first order of z
biotics pre-alcohol probiotic by
clicking the link in the description box
and use my code new rockstars at
checkout go to
xebiotics.comrockstars and get 15 off
your first order shuri in the lab greets
riri williams aka ironheart a brilliant
mit student an engineer played by
dominique thorne and she's going to be
getting her own disney plus series in
fall 2023. looks like sure he might be
doing some recruiting of great minds
from tony stark's alma mater now lizzy
should write as an actress is just very
thin but notice as she approaches
dominique thorne she has definitely put
on a bit of mass in her shoulders i only
bring this up because the final shot of
this trailer is just gonna force us to
pay close attention to all of these
actors physiques and right as shuri and
riri slap hands tim's repetition of
everything gonna be alright transitions
seamlessly into kendrick lamar's alright
like many bob marley songs lamar's
alright became a protest anthem he
conceived this track while visiting
south africa's robben island to see the
cell where nelson mandela was imprisoned
and he wrote these lyrics with an intent
to heal thereafter this song became a
key song for the blm movement both to
grieve but also to fight through that
grief and find a way to express joy and
to keep one's head up
[Applause]
[Music]
and i love how both of these songs in
this trailer work together to try to
comfort us to try to keep us strong
let's move on
[Music]
i am queen of the most powerful nixon in
the world
and my entire family
is gone
okay an interesting flashback shows this
ranch house on fire and then there's
like an old-timey carriage somewhat an
old-timey tired dead out front as a
young neymar gazes up at this fire with
four blue skinned atlanteans i assume
this is part of neymar's origin story
maybe the death of one of his parents
and the fact that this seems to be set
so far in the past might mean that they
give neymor a similar origin that he had
in the comics he could just be very old
someone who ages very slowly i like how
the atlanteans wear these breathing
masks over their faces but presumably to
circulate water into their mouths since
they might not be able to breathe air
but namor doesn't have to wear one
because he is part human but then we
have this match cut of adult namor
meeting the atlanteans on a different
shore this if you look at the structures
in the background is wakanda now wakanda
seemed to be in the middle of the
african continent but it did border a
body of water and if you look later on
in this trailer on the same beachfront
namor and the others face fire from a
wakandan aircraft as in baku leaps at
them from a boat but interesting how in
that shot the other atlanteans die back
in the water but neymar doesn't move
does he have some kind of divine
protection as the avatar of a mayan god
we return to the mountain kingdom of the
jabari tribe of umbacu notice the
snow-covered gorilla statue this may be
where the wakandans have to flee to
after the flooding since it's higher
ground raimonda addresses the u.n and
after that skirmish with the commandos
and the wakandan scientists i'm
wondering if she's now declaring that
wakanda is actually turning away from
the world community a reversal of her
son's address in the 2018 film and then
we get another shot at t'challa's
funeral ceremony showing his face on a
billboard with the wakandan letters
translating to the panther king forever
lives in us and rests with an unseen
with the and the last word is blocked
out but i see an es and based on the
spacing i think it's ancestors so the
panther king forever lives in us and
rests with the ancestors then there's
the yellow building below that's selling
wakandan something can't really make it
out let's move
on everything
[Music]
so the emotional speech given by ramonda
that i thought was in the u.n is
actually being delivered in the wakandan
throne room perhaps to the atlantean
invaders who are now demanding more from
her and she says my entire family is
gone so t'chaka and t'challa are gone
but what about shuri i would be really
surprised if shuri dies in this movie
but she may not be actually dead she
might just be in the ancestral plane and
ramona just thinks she's dead for sure
to access the ancestral plane she would
have to find a way to synthetically
regrow the heart-shaped earth the
ancestral plane could be where she
encounters her father t'chaka her
brother t'challa maybe in the form of a
silent panthers sitting in the tree but
also in the ancestral plane my friends
is likely her cousin killmonger i got
some more thoughts on that later we get
a clear shot of neymar's four atlantean
warriors on a bridge that kind of looks
like the same bridge over the potomac
that everett ross is walking on maybe
the atlantans also attack an american
military site like the pentagon which is
right along the potomac and that could
be what leads that steel team to
attacking the wakandan lab or intel on
the atlanteans or the vibranium and i
like that female atlantean has a
necklace but it looks like a barracuda
jawbone very cool then the shot of rio
williams hammering away in shuri's lab
popping out a piece of metal in the
shade of an iron heart iron art
suggesting that ribri williams iron
heart suit might actually be made of
vibranium then we see michaela cole's
character named aneka who is a former
member of the dormilage who in the
comics leaves and forms the midnight
angels her armor includes some wings
that enable her to fly now the midnight
angels are among other things known for
a certain mission with deadpool two kill
dr doom after doom steals all the
wakandan vibranium i don't know victor
von doom would be an interesting suspect
behind that initial land dweller
intrusion then a shot of namor looking
at this mayan art at least i think it's
mayan this mural depicts the feathered
serpent deity known as forgive my
pronunciation kukulkan which is the
mayan equivalent to quetzalcoatl of
aztec mythology so again the way that
the black panther uses the deity of boss
as his divine power serving as his
avatar the way moon knight serves as the
avatar to konchu i think the same
process is being used by neymar
empowered by a mayan god moving on
[Music]
so okoye fights the atlanteans on that
bridge that i mentioned before their
spear strikes pushing her back toward
the water you should note until she
plants her spear in the concrete then
some shots of a street chase with a
motorcycle and a red car and then
another shop within that red car shows a
drone plane crashing into a line of
police cars then a close-up of namor
with a necklace of pearls or could those
be comoyo beads probably pearls but they
also kind of look like moyo beads i just
really think the atlanteans may have
their own supply of vibranium and that
is why they were initially targeted
namor or some other atlantean descends
into this throne that is encased in the
jawbone of a shark i love how the top of
the jawbone has two rows of teeth
because sharks shed their teeth and then
a wakandan versus atlantean sea battle
dozens of atlanteans surrounding a
vessel in a coordinated strike and then
the dormilage leap off that deck
tethered to knock them off the side of
the vessel i love this jack sparrow [ __ ]
and i want to know what kind of ship
this is why are the wakandans venturing
out in the ocean i have a theory for why
they may be setting their sails in the
final section
ooh so who is our new black panther in
this black and gold suit i initially
thought shuri since you know leticia
wright has put on some muscle but based
on the silhouette i will say it looks
more like nakia who is the first
character we see in this trailer but at
the end of the day i couldn't be wrong i
just do think this figure looks a bit
more masculine to me and really the clue
i'm most interested in comes from the
line of kendrick lamar's alright that
googler cuts to black one
yes when i wake up if the reason ramonda
considers shuri dead is that shuri is in
the ancestral plane recruiting cousin
killmonger to wake him up to resurrect
him that could be how we get killmonger
back in the suit remember thor love and
thunders post credit scene showed jane
foster and heimdall in valhalla another
mcu afterlife alongside the ancestral
plane in the egyptian underworld in moon
knight and the reason we saw jane and
heimdall again i think was to indicate
the possibility of reincarnation or
resurrection in this universe remember
killmonger was buried at sea just bury
me in the ocean
with my ancestors that jumped from the
ships
because they knew death
was better than bondage
the atlanteans could have recovered his
body now remember ramona needed
t'challa's body to resurrect him from
the ancestral plane in the 2018 film
presumably to resurrect killmonger you
would need his body that could be why
they're headed out to the ocean and in
this trailer at the very beginning there
was one shot of shuri in which she is in
this golden hazy out-of-focus realm and
she's crying what is making her cry who
is she seeing who is she reuniting with
in this moment perhaps she could be in
her ancestral underworld waking up a
warrior to help her reclaim her home now
so much attention has been paid to who's
in the suit that some have overlooked
the context of this moment someone out
of focus is climbing back to their feet
on this beach framed in this panther's
claws now i assume it's neymar looks
like it's a blur of huawei's chest and
his green jammers golden gauntlets and
chess piece but if this beach is
wakandan that would mean this is
pre-blood because if they need those
floodwaters to rise enough to flood the
throne room there wouldn't be a
beachfront here so killmonger's
resurrection and conflict with namor in
this moment might actually be the thing
the moment of escalation that leads
atlantis to retaliate by flooding
wakanda a risk that killmonger might
consider worth taking as doctor strange
learned in multiverse madness
resurrecting the dead may seem like a
quick fix but in the grand scheme of
things it's an unholy action to unbury
the dead and can curse the living with
unintended consequences thank you so
much for watching this video you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow new rockstars and subscribe
to rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks again so much
for supporting this channel and i'll
catch you next time bye
[Music]
you